lives of Tik Tok dug up another good one
for us this this time it's a
self-described racial Justice Advocate
named Ali Henny who apparently has been
hired to give workshops on anti-racism
in the past and in a video which has
gone viral this week Henny explains how
punctuality is a feature of white
culture and it's racist for white people
to expect that non-white people will
show up on time to things
listen as a racial Justice Advocate I'm
often invited to give talks or to do
workshops where I talk to white people
about race a big part of my practice is
to offer real life stories examples that
type of thing that help white people to
be able to identify white supremacy in
everyday life my husband's family is
white and I often use a cultural
differences between my family and his
family as a way to help white people see
their whiteness there's one example that
I use that always gets a ton of push
back my husband and I were late to our
first Thanksgiving with his family I say
late because it started at 12:00 we got
there at 12:10 but whenever we got there
at 12:10 everybody was already sat down
and eating I didn't know that I Ed this
illustration to point out that different
cultures have different understandings
of time lateness and what it means to be
polite without fail a white person will
push back and say that lateness is
impolite I always use this as a
teachable moment I usually ask a series
of pointed questions that challenge
their assumptions sometimes it takes a
lot of work but by the end they're able
to identify how white cultural dominance
Works in this one small area of Life
which opens the door for them to start
peeling the
onion oh she didn't know that she didn't
know that if something starts at 12 and
you get there 10 minutes after the thing
starts you're late now you might think
that this is just the dictionary
definition of late you might wonder what
she could have imagined late means if it
doesn't apply to a circumstance or she
is arriving to a thing after the thing
has already started has she never
encountered the word late before did she
not was she unfamiliar with the concept
and she lived her whole life and never
been introduced to the concept of being
late now she said she had a different
concept of time well what is her concept
now it's true that time is relative in
the sense that you can have a
gravitational time dilation where where
effect where time slows down as the
force of gravity grows stronger but I
don't think Einstein's theory of
relativity ever suggested that time is
relative depending on the culture you
grew up in but before we expand on that
idea let's listen to the uh racial
Justice Advocates follow-up video where
she responds to uh some of the criticism
she has heard against this idea
listen hey this is my own comment and
it's in reference to the video that I
did about punctuality in white culture
I'm pretty sure if you tap it it'll take
you back to the original video but I
wanted to expand on this a little bit
specifically I wanted to challenge white
people to expand their thinking on this
topic the most common type of comment
that I saw in the original video was
some version of I'm white and I'm always
late I don't think that people were
trying to refute the premise of the
original video but I do think that white
people were trying to distance
themselves from this particular feature
of white culture here's where I want
y'all to dig a little bit deeper this is
something that I notice white people do
a lot whenever we talk about whiteness
there's an acknowledgement that a
certain type of whiteness exists but
also an attempt to say oh no I'm not
that type of white person here's the
problem with that a lot of times
whenever you try to distance yourself
from an aspect of whiteness you're
actually reinforcing that aspect of
whiteness so going back to the original
example when you say that you're light
you're still operating under dominant
cultured constructs of time and
punctuality you're still being white
about it here's what you missed there
are people who view the world very
differently from you and so you have to
train your brain to be able to see
things from a different perspective you
know this is something that I notice
black people do a lot that's why I
really want to challenge black people to
dig a little bit deeper I need you black
people to listen and learn from me about
how you should be behaving because you
know really you're being a little black
about it right
now see it sounds bad when I speak that
way to black people and it's no
different when this woman speaks the
same way to white people okay it's exact
just just exactly the same thing like we
don't need your lectures especially when
you're scolding us for objectively
positive traits like timeliness and
punctuality which which is an
unintentional compliment that plenty of
us don't actually deserve anyway but
this idea that basic etiquette and
politeness and professionalism are
constructs of whiteness or white culture
is pervasive we can't even give this
woman credit for having the originality
to come up with something so wacky on
her own she just repeating the sort of
driil that she's picked up from the
anti-racist racket you probably remember
that Infamous chart put together by the
Smithsonian uh claiming that things like
hard work and professionalism are white
constructs Museum took that chart down
in embarrassment after noticed it and
reacted the way normal people react to
insane things like that but the idea
hasn't gone away in fact just a few
months ago Time Magazine published an
interview with someone named Leah
Goodridge who's the author of a UCLA law
review article titled professionalism as
a racial construct and the claim is that
standards of professionalism of which
timeliness and punctuality are usually a
part are thinly veiled excuses to be
racist so you know our friend Ali Henny
didn't make this up she's not Innovative
enough to come up up with her own ways
to be dumb instead she's parting the
dumbness she's heard elsewhere but that
doesn't make it any less dumb of course
so have you ever browsed in incognito
mode it's probably not as Incognito as
you might think and why would it be
incognito mode has made big tech
companies a fortune by tracking your
movements online so how do you actually
make yourself as invisible as possible
online well you use expressvpn like I do
it turns out that even in incognito mode
your online activity still gets tracked
and data Brokers still get to buy and
sell data one of these data points is
your IP address data Harvesters use your
IP to uniquely identify you and your
location but with expressvpn your
connection gets rerouted through an
encrypted server and your IP address is
masked every time you connect to
expressvpn you get a random IP address
shared by many other expressvpn
customers that makes it harder for third
parties to identify you or harvest your
data best of all expressvpn is super
easy to use no matter what device you're
on phone laptop or smart TV all you got
to do is tap one button for instant
protection so if you really want to go
into in cognito and protect your privacy
secure yourself with the number one
rated VPN visit expressvpn.com Walsh and
get 3 months free that's exprss vpn.com
Walsh again that's expressvpn.com Walsh
to learn more and the first problem with
the race Hustlers claim that punctuality
is a feature of white culture is that in
most other circumstances race Hustlers
tell us that white people don't have a
culture just a few days ago at the start
of Black History Month Twitter was full
of these anti-racist types informing us
that white people don't get a history
month or any other specific cultural
recognition because whiteness is not a
culture that's what they say cim Rasheed
is a left-wing activist who's currently
running for congress announced that
quote there's no such thing as white
culture he said you know there could be
Italian culture and French culture and
Irish culture and so on but not white
culture now of course if that's true of
white people then it's just as true of
black people white is an umbrella that
includes many different people from many
different countries separated by hundred
or even thousands of miles um black is
also an umbrella that includes many
different people from many different
countries separated by hundreds or even
thousands of miles so people can have
different opinions about whether it
makes sense to talk about the culture of
an entire race of people regardless of
their nation of origin but wherever you
land on that question the answer has to
apply to white and black
equally but left-wing race activists
answer this question like they answer
every question depending on the
ideological needs of the moment and for
somebody like Ali Henny white people
have a culture when it comes time to
scold them for a perceived flaw but
white people definitely do not have a
culture in the sense of something that
should be celebrated and preserved in
fact I feel quite sure that she would
cringe in horror if a white person ever
said to her that we should preserve and
celebrate white
culture in that case she would say white
culture doesn't exist you can't even
preserve it it's not so white culture
only exists when we're criticizing it in
other words white is not a culture
unless you need white to be a culture
for the purpose of lecturing white
people yet if we are apparently
recognizing white as a culture for the
purpose of this discussion I would not
personally include punctuality as a
unique feature of it as much as I
appreciate the compliment nobody I work
with would be able to stomach my
hypocrisy if I said oh yeah we white
folks we're always on time always that's
one thing about us white folks we're
never late I haven't been on time to
record my show for example one single
day since approximately 2019 and I'm not
even joking now although I do appreciate
the excuse that this Tik Tock racial
Justice Advocate has now given me if
anybody complains that I'm late I can
now accuse them of of upholding white
supremacy I never thought of that before
but come to think of it I think she's
right indeed my chronic lateness is
really just my own personal effort to
decenter my whiteness so if anybody
complains about it I can say well excuse
me for decentering my
whiteness and really anyone who does
complain about it is essentially for all
intents and purposes morally speaking
Adolf Hitler that is the inevitable
conclusion that we must draw either that
or the expectation that you show up on
time is simply a basic standard of
conduct that applies to everybody and if
you fall short of that standard it's not
because of it's not because you're
unfamiliar with the customs of white
people but rather because of your own
personal
shortcomings now I can see why Al Ali
may prefer the latter
option um I may not prefer the latter
option I should say and you know the one
about the shortcomings I don't prefer it
either but at least I have the courage
to admit my own
shortcomings even if I won't do anything
to correct them but that much cannot be
said about ali Henny the racial Justice
Advocate and that is why she is today
canell if You' like to see what I have
to say you can access my full show by
going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed